on
[Musique]
oui bien venir faire un résultat ici
c'est melissa maulin 10 puis alors vous
comprendrez que je suis de l'extérieur
une belle jours de pluie on n'en demande
pas plus pour le premier temps il faut
nourrir ces articles qui vont sortir
leurs feuilles d'ailleurs mais je
m'égare d'obsèques quand même pour faire
un sujet super important qui pour moi
est la lutte environnementale mais pas
uniquement la lutte environnementale je
dirais les pires sexualité entre les
luttes rectum et les luttes
environnementales
pourquoi on parle d'un corps sectionné
dit pourquoi on pas au même de
discrimination de racisme au sein les
luttes environnementales sait qu'on va
avoir beaucoup de points de
conversations entre les deux milieux
autour notamment de la discrimination
environnemental autour de racisme
environnementale et c'est un juge était
très difficile à avoir parce que vous
avez entendu dernièrement le racisme
systémique et vous savez comment la
conversation a été très compliqué à
avoir avec nous vernement avec les
citoyens imaginez ce genre de lutte lors
de ce genre de discussions le même qui a
lieu mais au sein de la mouvance
environnemental fait quand même quelques
dizaines d'années qu'on essaye de
transformer le milieu environnemental de
leurs des colonisés et le processus
s'est quand même fait plus rapidement
avec justement les groupes
environnementaux les les militants
environnementaux parce que cette
discussion là est venu avec leurs
intérêts avec leurs points de vue et
aussi leurs observations sur le terrain
c'est que pendant des décennies on
nautique et les changements climatiques
elle avait des conséquences des
conséquences discriminatoires envers les
communautés autochtones en premier parce
qu'on était sur l'intérêt parce que les
conséquences des changements climatiques
allait se ressentir sur les communautés
autochtones et pas uniquement que mon
doigt comme des les communautés racisées
les femmes les enfants les uns étude des
groupes y ont souvent aujourd'hui un
billet 10 finalement au dessus de leurs
têtes vont avoir à subir les
conséquences des changements climatiques
plus drastiquement cette voix qui ont
fait paraître accès aux mêmes pouvoirs à
la main argent que des personnes souvent
pouvoir compris je dois les effets des
changements
mathé mais pourquoi est-ce que entre la
lutte environnementale et les
autochtones
on voit une relation de secret je dirais
que j'ai beaucoup observé à partir de
mai dit ans avec un grand nombre
quand les mouvances environnementale et
rénovant 70 se sont joints au tour d'un
des coins de compassion que la mouvance
dans les deux mois qui était on a enlevé
des protections à l'eau on revient voilà
par le gouvernement harper de pouvoir et
aussi les normes et courent autour de
tout ce qui était des conditions de vie
a été une communauté à côté des mains
des mines de diamants de beers
même les sables bitumineux donc à cette
époque mais une grosse une grosse
cohésion que s'est faite entre les
groupes environnementale et lino votre
actuelle cependant c'est pas parfait
les groupes environnementaux ont eu
beaucoup de travail de vie colonisation
à faire au sein même de leur idéologie
de la re mobilisation pendant longtemps
mais pourquoi les besoins des
communautés autochtones pourquoi est-ce
qu'on doit parler de justice de justice
environnementale
alors qu'on devrait tout concentré sur
l'environnement pour c'est que pendant
longtemps on voyait pas que les raisons
pour lesquelles on se mobilise dans les
groupes autochtones étaient pas
exactement les mêmes raisons qu'il faut
lesquels les groupes environnementaux
sont immobilisés mais les deux combinés
ensemble a mené une puissance d'écouté
et de fera au niveau idéologique qui
faisait que cette intersectionnelle
devait se créent alors je suis
maintenant que je travaille dans le
milieu environnemental 10 chez moi
j'étais pas une environnementaliste à la
base chez fanny nous il ya une culture
qui est énormément centré autour de la
protection
ça lui a donné que la cohésion du big
three avec le groupe environnemental
peut faire en sorte que mon travail
prenait 10 ans mais je n'aurais jamais
fait cette cohésion l'a6 et la vie
politique
je vais rencontrer des gens venant
légaux qui eux mêmes avaient commencé un
processus de décolonisation qui eux
mêmes avaient sorti de leurs idées les
luttes de justice climatique n'était pas
aussi important que la lutte de
protection d'environnement et pourquoi
est ce parce que présentement quand on
fait des luttes environnementales des
fois ça y est avec pour six départs
matic de privilèges
je donne un exemple si on va vers
uniquement les moteurs électriques par
exemple ça va demander des batteries au
lithium et nous votons allait prendre
notre source de lithium quel genre de
changements géopolitiques par exemple on
va voir arriver à cause justement du
désir pour des minérais pour la
transition vient donc même des gens qui
font la transition vers conte de plus en
plus une réflexion sur une transition
juste vers alors pour moi ça répond
justement c'est besoin de cohésion entre
notre bureau est de plus en plus grâce à
l'exemple existe justement dans les
groupes environnementaux qui sont aussi
en progression qui sont aussi un conte
travail continue eh bien les milieux de
la santé par exemple de l'éducation
peuvent prendre exemple sur le travail
qui a déjà été fait par rapport à
l'intersexualité entre ces groupes là
puisque c'est quand même une question
d'avenir et d'urgence celle de protéger
la planète et c'est une des raisons pour
laquelle moi je me suis engagé par
exemple dans le meilleur environnement
parle n'est pas nécessairement mon
milieu naturel si je peux me permettre
parce que pour moi tout est question des
enjeux de langue de culture des droits
des femmes les droits des aînés tout ça
dépend principalement de l'environnement
ce territoire de la protection de ce
territoire
tous ceux et soutenue par la terre et
par sa protection donc c'est pour ça que
j'ai pu rentrer dans ce milieu là et
trouvait justement un terrain d'entente
pour que nourrissent travailler ensemble
et aller encore plus loin et un des
moments
fort que je dirais qu'il m'a vraiment
inspirée c'est quand on a marché en 2019
avec denver et que je voyais trente
jeunes alignés tous ensemble qu'ils
marchaient ensemble qu'ils avaient
forcée du jour n'en sommes à parler
justement de justice environnementale et
de leur travail futur ensemble et qu'on
était en train de marcher c'est fou
j'aurais jamais pu penser à ça dix ans
auparavant
et maintenant je le vois que ça se
réalise donc cette progression là est
vraiment quelque chose qui va nous
donner une base pour s'inspirer pour
d'autres quels sont vos trucs et je vous
invite justement découvrir les îles
maman de justice réparatrice qui existe
dans les milieux environnement de voir
aussi comment on peut travailler
ensemble avoir une cohésion sur les
territoires éloignés
en gros à l'automne et groupes
autochtones qui sont partis sur des
bases différentes mais qui se rejoignent
sur une tonne alors je devais semaine un
bon jour de la terre et j'espère que
vous partagerez vidéo que vous essayez
donc à partager des sources de format
podcast on n'a pas la chronique par la
table
je souhaite une belle semaine